prieur une marque des scream reconnu
dans le monde entier
une partie des ateliers se trouvent à
montceau les mines ici quatre
couturières seulement travaillent sur le
textile très technique de la marque gage
d'élégance de confort mais aussi de
sécurité
christian nauté patron de mcd confection
est en contrat avec la marque prieur
depuis plus de 20 ans il est très
attaché au savoir faire local pour
fabriquer un pantalon on à 37 minutes
pour fabriquer une veste on à 55 minutes
pour saboter une bavette on a 17 minutes
ces détails qui sont assez courts la
marque prieur s'installe à montceau les
mines dans les années 80 leader sur le
marché mondial
elle confectionne tout sur place masques
et paix vêtements son chiffre d'affaires
atteint alors les trois millions d'euros
pour une trentaine de salariés mais dans
les années 2000 l'entreprise perd de sa
superbe
elle est rachetée en 2014 ces ateliers
principaux sont transférées deux ans
plus tard à genlis en côte-d'or masqué
et p ils sont confectionnés grâce à
didier contrepoids entrepreneurs et
passionné des scream
il ne pouvait se résigner à la
disparition du savoir faire c'est un
challenge très très difficile et on en
n'est pas complètement sorti non plus
une entreprise était en très mauvaise
santé et il a fallu repartir même pas de
zéro mais de bien bien plus bas que 0
donc on a refait tous les fondamentaux
sur le plan industriel organisationnelle
dans ses ateliers 1600 l'âme et 1000
masques sont confectionnés à la main
vous avez cette pièce iconique qu'on
essaie de nous copier le becquet un
marché de niche dans lequel prière
souhaite retrouver sa place de numéro 1
en 2012 aux jo de londres la marque
bourguignonne perd son contrat avec
l'équipe de france des screen au profit
d'une marque anglaise
et la chine se met aussi à développer sa
gamme de moins bonne qualité elle est
surtout moins cher et inondent le marché
français avec son âme de compétiteur
d'yves les contrepoids voit dans cette
concurrence
l'occasion de montrer sa détermination
et c'est ce qu'on retrouve aussi dans
les scream on a besoin d'adversité on a
besoin d' obstacles on a besoin des
problématiques difficiles nous soit
présenté pour s'y confronter et pour les
20 ans alain travailler dans les anciens
ateliers de montceau les mines l'isle
est le seul à savoir confectionner ses
épées prière au film mois pendant lequel
il faut que ce soit dans le fond de la
réunion
donc il faut je creuse de façon à ce que
le fils touche tous non ça c'est à
l'oeil c'est l'habitude quatre ans après
leur achat
la marque tomber un chiffre d'affaires
de 350 mille euros en 2014 est estimée
aujourd'hui à 1 million d'euros et son
patron voit encore plus loin
mon ambition si vous voulez c'est de
faire en sorte que prieur soit dotée de
tous les atouts dont elle a besoin pour
redevenir le leader mondial
alors ça paraît très ambitieux mais je
pense que prieur a les moyens de le
faire ça mettra probablement cinq six
huit dix ans peut-être mais les
fondations qu'on a
reconstruite sont des fondations solides
on va pouvoir monter là dessus des murs
et je l'espère les élever à s'est
dernièrement prieur a décroché un
contrat avec une salle d'armes à
shanghai en chine et la marque vient de
recevoir une commande de new york pour
équiper certains athlètes de l'équipe
américaine
[Musique]